all right guys leaving Sacramento this
is the last leg of the trip where are we
going monkey Cheeto San Francisco San
Francisco
oh yeah for my cousin so my cousin
graduated med school and then we brought
this little monkey dude I think you're
only like eight months or something at
that time you're an itty bitty guy you
couldn't even walk you know that
you remember that part yeah
yeah you're a little yeah so we're gonna
stop by San Francisco on the way to
grandma's house so that we could
celebrate her birthday with her tomorrow
okay good job thank you for your little
ruler
what did the baby chicken say to his mom
your time for falling off what your
pills are falling off
all your tails
pounds pants or your pants Oh what's the
chicken doing with pants on
it's funny
I had another chicken had pants on I
like that it has pants what color are
the pants
[Music]
ready yeah
what did the monkey say to the other
monkey
what are you doing Google
no he said
can I have my hat back
it didn't it didn't hit gotta work on
that one huh
what monkey did they send to the other
monkey
what are the other monkeys into the
other monkey yeah
armpits smell
you know he said take a shower because
you feel really bad and eat the last
banana
cheesy feet
oh why is that a lot of stuff
what did the cat say to the other cat I
don't know
he said
funny
what did the ocean say to the river
oh other than you
said
and then he said
let's look up the trees baby what does a
River's feet look like
like that
my two hats
all right I see something in the horizon
that is uh
that is a cloudy ass San Francisco
excited for the Cloudy dirty San
Francisco
you're gonna see a really cool bridge
and then I'm gonna take you to
Fisherman's Wharf we're gonna see some
seals
that's how seals make sounds how they
bark like that you know
that's what I saw just like that
no gross
here we go I like Bridges we're about to
drive over a bridge not the Golden Gate
Bridge which is not gold you just found
out huh
it's red why would they do that
the red color golden yeah whoa look at
this this one's called the Bay Bridge
it's a white bridge and then there's
Gates and there's a bridge
yeah did you hear what Papa said
yeah what is this bridge called
it's right here monkey look Bay Bridge
I know that all right babe
I'm so glad we don't use the word bae
anymore
that's my bay yeah
yeah that's my babe and more of the
destruction the nature destruction Papa
likes he likes when they build into
nature so look that is pretty cool
though a tunnel underneath all that
green
that is kind of cool yeah but I bet it
heard it are you sure it was a big owl
week
hold your breath make a wish
there good guys look at this bridge this
bridge is beautiful
no
another Bay Bridge you see all those
buildings over there that's San
Francisco monkeys
right there yeah that is a Golden Gate
Bridge the red one over there
it's so huge but it is a cool though it
is the golden Bay Bridge
wait what is it called it's not the
called the Golden Berry Bridge what is
it called now I'm calling it something
else it's not the Golden Gate Bridge
anymore oh I called it the golden Bay
Bridge
it's the red
Red Gate Bridge the red gay Bridge
this is red I think you're combining
some letters that don't need to go
together my dude oh no
it's always so beautiful to see like so
many skyscrapers like on water side like
I've had a big Affinity towards cities
like that like Chicago have you been to
Miami
all right Miami's like that tacos like
that Boston's like that I really like
where it's all built on the water it's
so beautiful it is beautiful
never seen this before tsunami Hazard
Zone in case of an earthquake go to High
grounds or Inland or a tsunamis caused
by earthquakes
I'm so uneducated on stuff like that I
don't want to be in some Navi don't be a
tsunami like surface
I'm sorry you have to sit there and
listen to all of this dumb conversation
I'm sorry this is cute conversation
somebody saved me please
Mia you've been so many places this trip
you two monkey man you went to Death
Valley
Mammoth Lake Tahoe Sacramento San
Francisco yeah
you're a traveling man and not careful
careful yeah and we're California right
now and so have you Mia and you're not
even a year yeah you crazy bones
that's crazy
let's go dude
all right we are officially here
the Fisherman's Wharf of San Francisco
first stop to look for the seals do you
remember where the steel I feel like
I've been here but I haven't been here
and things look different I remember
remember this one of our first uh travel
dates whoa look at our hands were they
just touching well that's crazy what
what is this oh God kiss oh how cute
remember it's one of our first like
travel dates together yeah
in the car we had sdx in the carpet what
are you going
yeah and you're the result of it
I forgot where the seals are
but we are in the marina
and there are a ton of boats here which
is really cool
maybe it's over there
I have no idea but you know what I do
remember babe no
car
it's the result of this
look at the water nothing I don't know
it's green all right so Pier 39 is where
all the sea lions are okay that's where
you want to go if you're in San
Francisco
are you ready mister are you ready to
see some sea lions yes
all right so we got taika in the
captain's chair so we can see these sea
lions better because he does not believe
that they're here you don't see them you
can hear them already over there they're
right on the they're at the bottom where
all the people are
in front of the people yeah you see them
okay wait look you see the guy with the
green shirt
yeah okay so in front of that guy on the
bottom yeah they're all right there
a little brown they look like brown pine
cones
just trust me okay we're gonna see them
okay yeah we got you in the captain's
chair so you're gonna see them
what'd you say
what you see one
let me
swimming in the ocean self
no do you hear all his friends they're
really close
you hear it they go oh
you see it
do you hear them yeah
yeah
we're here to see the sea lions not the
Ducks
okay you see them right there look
they're all right there look there's a
company here there's like 20 of them
well they're relaxing they're taking a
break
you hear them
no they're taking a little break you
hear them
look look they're right there at least
the company they're up here 39. oh it's
at least one do you see them at least
one is hiding under the water yeah
okay we're getting really close okay
mister
do you see them yeah yeah
look they're right here
look look how close we are look they're
right there look they're ginormous huh
look how big they are
yeah well they're sleeping look
they're having to take a little nap
look at that look how many they are
you guys are water dogs Mia hey they're
your cousins yeah they're your cousins
yeah they are okay you want to go inside
here we go one two three
was that scary
it is not a complete San Francisco trip
unless you get some world famous
sourdough
from Boone
and not to mention it's not a complete
trip if you don't grab clam chowder in a
bread bowl and they have that here too
so we're gonna grab a sourdough bread
for Jill's mom because she loves
sourdough and they're also going to grab
lunch get some clam chowder and then
head on next to our next location which
will be the Golden Gate Bridge
oh look at this fresh Made bread look at
all the little shapes she's making
and it looks like this monkey look
there's a teddy bear and an alligator
you see that
yeah it's that small and look how big it
gets
really big kind of reminds me of the one
time where me and my bear
in the car trip to San Francisco
so Mama put me in charge of getting a
bread for Grandma and her brother's
family so I think I'm gonna have to get
some shaped ones because there's all
kinds it was like the Bears right there
there's also a turtle which is pretty
cool
and little buddies or something
oh look at all this baked goods
mama look at the breads I got yes
okay you got the kitty on top no I
didn't
it's a barrel we could count on you if
you have a cutie cuties look at the
other one the other one's even cute here
that's a big crab
Kitty pictures
I didn't go on too many trips as a kid
you know yeah my family so I like I like
documenting what we get to go through
excuse me what'd you get so I got the
clam chowder and the sourdough bread and
then this looked really good the uh
French dip
look at that that's toasted sourdough
yeah it's like it's been dying for some
bread he loves bread okay mister all
right
this looks like good
good meat right there oh and sourdough
you know how it's like kind of rough but
once you soak it it's gonna be the
perfect
wow crunchy crunch crunch
on camera
oh my God look at your face
face
you have it all the meat all over your
face it took out the back of my throat
oh my God yep literally meat all over
here it's really good okay it's not a
good commercial but it's really good you
have to wait all over your face
you okay it's really good yeah are you
sure yeah okay
okay monkey before we leave do you
remember one last thing we got to do
we have to get a
okay I'm gonna get a sticker it's gonna
be mine it's gonna be so cool no way no
way no way impossible
[Music]
all right let's see let's get some
magnets what's a good magnet yeah for
Grandma let's oh it's going with the
Golden Gate Bridge on it do you see
anyone oh that one looks good so let's
get this one but that's the red one yeah
that one's CUNY it's rainbow and it has
a Golden Gate Bridge dude but that's the
Red Gate Bridge because he has the red
game picture right they should rename it
tell them tell them okay now we got now
we gotta get a sticker
wow
wow of course
every time we
blocked by trees
you ready to see the Red Gate Bridge
[Music]
are you mad
why
yep
tiger is being greedy and not wanting to
share so he was stuffing a bunch of
candy in his mouth so that whoa there it
is the Red Gate Bridge Monday is huge
wow wow we driving on this
oh
beautiful I wish I was in coffee
look at that wow
and
I think it's my first time on it oh
really yeah look even on the map it's
the Red Gate Bridge oh cute they made it
the same color I've never been on it
before not together mister
grumpy
I got a document this moment
what I was saying is yeah taika just
kept stuffing candy in his mouth because
he didn't want anyone else to eat it and
I'm like dude that's so rude we're
supposed to share that's horrible you
don't do that ever so then I made him
spit out like four or five pieces that
he had in his mouth and I made him throw
it away because I'm like if you're not
gonna share you're not gonna get any at
all
so that's why we're like this right now
yep even though we're traveling
parenting comes first yep so this might
seem like a really good view of the
Golden Gate Bridge
and yes indeed it is I Googled it and I
followed the road to here look at this
beautiful Bay over here but if you look
closely all the way over there
it's even better
so that's we're gonna end the trip we're
gonna end the trip over there with the
super close view snapshot of the Golden
Gate Bridge
and we'll head back down to LA
which means we'll probably get there at
like eight or nine
but what a great trip
so this little Trail
is probably like a good
10 minute walk five ten minute walk but
it's worth it because you're up close
and personal
you can even hear the cars
you hear the cars
traveling
all the way over there
and we're just over that hump
I must say the little hike was worth it
because look at this
holy moly now that is a dope shot look
at that dude
kind of small those cars are I never
realized how big
the Golden Gate bridges thank you